driver
face away
[Music]
approaching
lpf
if that trooper can get in and tbi this
murder suspect
like no traffic no traffic
no traffic
yep southbound up here southbound
delaware
ahead
southbound southbound still
downtown
peace
[Music]
foreign
traveling south 13th street
coming upon
four half
[Music]
coming up the 23rd
yeah we're all in it together here just
clear the airport
[Music]
southbound towards the bypass
hp's helicopter available get everything
uh we can go in here still southbound
we're working on it
one direction on 23rd
we're past 23rd we're still southbound
coming up to haskell 33rd and haskell
area
[Music]
passing 31st
we're going under the bypass bridge
right now
signaling to get on the bypass
traffic we're going to be going
or what's on the bike
okay just let's give him some room here
[Music]
more shots fired at about 34th get on
the bypass eastbound
[Music]
they're aware of the of the afternoon is
that correct
they're aware they're looking on their
own
they don't have availability
i've got the radio
he's found speeds about a hundred
do we have permission to leave the back
to assist
still eastbound
97 miles an hour
being different
general no no big passion to reach more
damage but
make sure they're aware
we're staying eastbound we're passing
the 23rd street exit still eastbound
about 90 some miles an hour 93 ish
okay here
um
some of the units in the back of this
when he sees all these lights up here be
ready in case he tries to go through the
median to flip around
i'll be on the south side of the highway
capacity 1900 s e 1900
100 miles an hour
four shots fire
just shot at the eudora officer
10 more
so
the vehicles
coming up to you
facts
did he hit
him bye
did you did he hit the spikes
okay
slowing down
somebody can get the rifle out
got his hands out the window everybody
stay back
stop
[Music]
driver
face away
step out
[Music]
walk straight backwards
if you try to run
you'll be bit by the dog
on the side of the road yeah on that
side there's a passenger laying down
not that i know of
keep blocking anderson we can land him
over here
yes
step to the right
keep stepping keep stepping
stop
back up keep stepping
keep coming
keep
coming keep coming
all right get on the ground
keep your hands out to your side like an
airplane hold on hold on hold on lay
down on your stomach all the way down
hands out watch your legs
behind
hey she's in the ditch walk her back to
us she's involved
[Applause]
arms out lay on your face put your hands
out
cross your ankles
don't move
you